il avait deux bandes ne va pas se
soumettre à un vote de confiance à
l'étude son discours de politique
générale c'est un peu de faiblesse non
mais n'y est pas obligé je pense que le
plus faire ça n'est pas parce que ça
n'est pas inscrit dans le décret que la
première ministre ne pourrait pas le
faire aucune porte n'est fermée et au
moment où je vous parle ce vote de
confiance est tout à fait possible elle
n'a pas pris sa décision et c'est à elle
de la prime alors je pense qu'il vaut
mieux que nous nous mettions au travail
le plus rapidement possible j'ai entendu
les discussions je pense que la phase de
dialogue était nécessaire avec tous les
groupes d'opposition pense que c'est un
sujet qui mérite qu'on y réfléchisse je
vais pas faire tout développement sur le
sens de le faire ou de ne pas le faire
mais donc je prendrai ma décision à
l'issue des consultations il n'a jamais
été question pour nous de coalition il
n'a jamais été question pour nous de
rentrer au gouvernement
mélenchon qui parle de petits
arrangements entre amis alors lui il dit
la présidence lrm et lui dit elle et
renaissance élu avec l'abstention du rn
un moment de honte est vite passé
bienvenue dans le monde va pouvoir battu
dans les urnes qui se maintient une fois
de plus il est en train d'en fumer
en fumée les français la réalité c'est
que jean luc mélenchon n'a pas sorti de
la tête sa volonté d'être premier
ministre qui se maintient avec des
petits arrangements même pas entre amis
des petits arrangements d'amis même
brune peavey l'avait 242 voix voilà donc
on peut tourner ça comme on veut elle
aurait été le choix au deuxième tour
soit au troisième tour les députés macro
nist ont saisi ambulants même sur lequel
il y avait les noms de sébastien chenu
et d'hélène la porte et l'on glissé dans
l'urne voilà c'est pas un acte anodin et
rien qu'à tenait son côté qui est
organisée est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
plutôt en train de faire diversion parce
que vous êtes un fichu un foutu pardon
pour l'expression au sein de la nièce de
vous mettre d'accord vous même la france
est elle
des crimes en algérie où la vous poser
une question crémone algérie je ne passe
pas non franchement avec des queues des
crimes en algérie non l'armée française
je ne pense pas
histoire mais je ne pense pas est ce que
vous faites pas un petit peu de nouveau
été porté vers les autres quoi enfin
lorsque ces 8 chez vous c'est vous qui
fait diversion et qui avait envie de
détourner le regard du fait essentiel
c'est que des députés macro nice ont
saisi un bulletin de vote du
rassemblement national et ont voté pour
eux incertains de journalistes se sont
précipités pollution lui pour lui poser
des questions sur le s il a dit je ne
suis absolument pas là pour parler de
ces sujets là disent ses bases ce
qu'elle est c'est une chose très claire
oui je voyais bien dans les journaux il
y avait des morts du côté de loeb les
mains nues et des crimes non franchement
je ne suis pas là pour juger s'il wells
a commis des crimes je sais même pas ce
que c'était l'ouest n'est presque pas
cette armée de libération nationale
algérienne d'obédience socialiste et
communiste il faut le dire a pomy là-bas
des crimes contre l'humanité et c'est
vrai qu'il ya deux poids deux mesures le
plus de victimes c'est d'abord par le
fln est ce que vous souteniez à l'époque
madame l epad antifédéraliste votre ceux
qui sont dans votre parti à l'époque ils
soutenaient plutôt ceux qui portaient
des valises pour armer les adversaires
de l'armée française et on a vu les
propos abjects de madame rousseau qui je
dois dire se singularise d'un dans la
dans la débilité profonde depuis
maintenant un certain nombre de mois il
n'y avait que monsieur gonzalez mais ya
monsieur haliocap à ces trois jours à
célébrer l'algérie française et à
glorifier certaines personnalités de
l'eau claire en ce ce sont des
terroristes monsieur raoult la centrale
y ont été commis au s dédiabolisation du
fn a pris fin dès la première séance
défendront d'autres discours à
l'assemblée nationale et des fonds la
mémoire de la guerre d'algérie mais du
côté de l'indépendance le député nubes
louis boyard qui a refusé de saluer
philippe bayard ballard le député
rassemblement national de l'oise madame
bazin malgras
pour les futurs débats qui vont avoir
lieu je pense que ça présage des moments
extrêmement tendue l'épidémie de kovy 19
poursuit sa progression en france
regardez les derniers chiffres plus de
cent quarante sept mille nouveaux cas
ont été confirmés en 24 heures